you are watching The Press preview and
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with journalist and author Rachel shabby
and director of the onward Think Tank
Sebastian Payne so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
will gp's scrap services to cope with
strikes is on the front of the telegraph
as routine appointments are suspended
for up to a week to help deal with the
junior doctor's walkout
the eye also calls attention to the
upcoming strike disruption the headline
of Pharmacists drafted in to offset
Hospital strike chaos
and the mirror which leads with the
headline Hospital Trek Scandal has one
in three 999 patients have had to make
their own way to hospital
meanwhile the male refers to the latest
labor posters with this quote by leaders
Dharma as he stands by every word made
by his party
similarly the times says labor will
blame the Prime Minister for crashing
the economy and continue to launch more
provocative ads
whilst The Daily Express writes about
the bank's betrayal of loyal customers
as findings suggest millions of
customers prefer face-to-face banking
rather than online
and the Daily Star speculates what kind
of life could be found on Jupiter
interesting and a reminder that by
scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us and we are
joined tonight by Rachel shabby and
Sebastian Payne welcome to you both let
us start with the telegraph
um and their front page gp's struggle
due to the strike services and they're
going to struggle with with services and
serving the the public because of the
the reduced numbers and take us into
this story first of all Rachel
sure so this has been reported by the
Telegraph and of course all the papers
as well
um there is a junior doctor's strike to
set to begin on Tuesday lasting for four
days and it's thought that up to 47
000 Junior doctors will be on strike
during that period so obviously that's a
lot of Staff
um that aren't going to be around and so
um both the unions and the government
actually are warning people of what to
expect over the coming days but it is
worth pointing out and I think someone
from the BMA Junior doctors Association
um did say this earlier on sky that
patients are already facing
um these sort of the the crisis in the
Health Service they're all Eddie having
Services impacted they're already facing
delays whether it's for surgery or for
Cancer Care or for routine appointments
those delays are a product of
under-resourcing short staffing shortage
of beds uh lack of social care lack of
community care and that's exactly why uh
junior doctors are going out on strike
it's partly about those conditions that
are simply unsustainable so I think the
government will find that despite all
the you know disadvantages
and the lack of availability of services
this week there is still very strong
public support uh for doctors and
support for what they're striking over
and according to this this article
Sebastian it it seems that the impact of
the strike is going to be far why than
perhaps initially anticipated
that's right the telegraph thoughts that
000 appointments are expected to be
canceled which is well upon the 175
000 predicted for this strike and Dr
Stephen Powers who's I think the medical
director of NHS England has said you
know look this is piling pressure on the
Health Service where it's already
dealing with the long backlogs due to
covid and of course this is not the the
first strike for eight
yeah oh hello
go ahead uh Sebastian sorry we had a
problem with the sama
oh no worries I was just saying I don't
know if you caught any of that but uh
it's gonna be 375
000 appointments that are likely to be
canceled and due to the strike this week
well up on the 175 000 that was
predicted before and Dr Stephen Powers
will remember him from all the covert
press conferences whose medical director
of NHS England he is saying that uh it's
going to power huge pressure on and it's
urging people to try and stay away from
hospitals from GP appointments unless it
is absolutely necessary and of course
the whole thing is devastating for
Health Service already struggling with
the backlog from the coronavirus
pandemic and so you know really I think
everyone just wants a deal to be done on
this and negotiations are still sort of
going on backwards and forwards between
the government and the BMA to try and
come to a resolution on this but I think
last thing everybody wants because
there's 96 hours strike is going to be
the most disruptive yet and really no
side seem to be looking to back down the
government's still trying to put forward
more money but but not quite enough to
help empty satisfy the BMA and the BMA
is holding firm and I know plenty of
Junior doctors admired you feel very
distressed by the situation they're
there to try and help patients help get
through the backlog but at the same time
they feel they deserve a pay rise so
hopefully we this will be the last of
these strikes we can get to some
resolution but at the moment it doesn't
look hugely positive yes I mean
unprecedented that the length of time I
think that's the thing that will be most
uh damaging people are most fearful of
um staying with the Health Service let's
move to the mirror Rachel and this story
about
um patients 999 patients and one in
three being forced to make their own way
to uh any accidents emergency
yeah it's a really
religion I mean we all
um have loved ones that you know people
who are elderly and perhaps vulnerable
and we think about you know what would
happen God forbid if they were to
require an ambulance service and would
have to wait and we just heard I think a
few days ago in Norfolk
um a man died after having a heart
attack and waiting a little bit too long
for an ambulance that that arrived too
late so it is an incredibly frightening
situation with these wait times for
ambulances
um it's completely unsustainable
um and it is just again it always part
of the same picture with a Health
Service that is chronically critically
underfunded uh severe staff shortages
just unsustainable staff levels and the
staff that are working whether that's
ambulance workers or Junior doctors or
nurses who by the way it's very unusual
for these health workers to go on strike
so it speaks to how severe the situation
is but certainly the situation they're
facing is of stress burnout
extraordinarily High rates of depression
anxiety the impact on mental health so
it just does speak to a very desperate
situation all around and one that really
can only be resolved with government
intervention with resources and with
funding with giving health workers the
pay that they deserve and giving all of
us the health care that we deserve and
it does seem truly shocking Sebastian
the mirror here suggesting that the poll
found that those needing Urgent Care
were driving or taking taxis trains or
even buses
to get to any
and DNA just speaks to The Strain the
Health Services Under at the moment and
I think the number one thing to
alleviate the stream would be to try and
solve a deal on this pay issue because
obviously there's much bigger factors at
play for the Health Service in terms of
uh there's the the future structure of
it the president's facing with social
care the Aging population and I think
obviously the strikes have really made
this particularly worse but I think
during the ambulance driver's strike
I've recalled the stories we're pretty
right for people having to make their
own way through various different ways
to hospitals so you know again this is
not really surprising and I just think
the the app Supreme has to be on trying
to get some kind of resolution to this
and I think there's a story in the on
the front of the eye paper tomorrow that
again speaks to the kind of the lengths
things gonna have to go to that
pharmacists are being drafted in to try
and offset the hospital chaos and of
course that's not a situation that
should ever have to happen but
unfortunately we are where we are with
this and I think that you know it's good
to see people are doing their best to
try and help out but it's to not be in
this in this situation yeah so Rachel
Sebastian suggests the front of the eye
um looking to the story of Pharmacists
actually having to to come in and roll
up sleeves and get involved to help I
mean how particularly will they be able
to to help cover for for junior doctors
I think that's a really good question
and I I wonder how pharmacists
themselves feel about that
um whether they feel that that is a
suitable
um measure to be taking whether they
feel they are qualified to do that I
mean of course pharmacists have an
incredibly deep knowledge of
um medical conditions
um as well as of obviously the the the
drugs that are being dispensed but you
you do have to wonder
um how they feel about being drafted in
this way I think there's an
extraordinary amount of pressure going
on within the NHS not just looking at
the pharmacists who are being asked to
do this but also
um consultants and doctors who are not
on strike
um I think some people have described it
as bullying actually just sort of being
corralled and pressured into
um you know rolling up their sleeves and
diving in in a way that doesn't really
seem fair or sustainable for the staff
that being asked to do this so again
it's speaks to the urgency for the
government to just get around a
negotiating table and sort this out
offer doctors pay that is actually
decent and fair a reminder that doctors
aren't actually asking for a pay rise
they're asking for pay restitution
because their pay has taken such a hit
over the last decade and a bit they are
just asking for a restoration so that it
is at least in line with inflation that
is not a pay rise that is just asking to
stand still welcome back to both of you
let's start with the Telegraph and the
headline
below the picture of the um
Princess of Wales Northern Ireland
pieces fragile in Wake of threats says
Minister this is a Chris Hayden Harris
the Northern Ireland Minister and this
is the
well the warning I guess before the
anniversary tomorrow of the um Northern
Ireland agreement and also before the
visit of President Biden
Sebastian yeah yes I thought I might be
going that my direction that one um yes
I mean obviously there's been a lot of
um stuff ridden over the weekend about
the 25th anniversary of the Good Friday
agreements some very good insight into
what happened then but also the
relevance to where we are now in this
article by Chris Heaton Harris is
warning that even though obviously the
good fight agreement has stood 25 years
that politics and peace in Northern
Ireland are not necessarily in the best
possible place because first of all and
storm into 70 isn't up and running that
despite the The Winds of framework Rishi
sunak brought together to try and mend
some of the issues with brexit Northern
Ireland the dup have not gone into
Stormwind so there's no government in
Northern Ireland and the second of all
is still warning that that there may
well potentially be threats to the peace
generally there so I think it's a very
good Stark reminder of the fact that you
know although there's a lot to celebrate
25 years on tonight historical core
things could still be a lot better and
need to be be a lot better in Northern
Ireland too
and Rachel do you think the presence of
President Biden will go some way towards
helping to restore power sharing and
also that the timing the 25th
anniversary do you think that the timing
and everything will work together to
come to that conclusion
it might do I mean I think
um President Biden visiting is obviously
uh an important step and I think it's
also an endorsement uh for sunac on an
international stage and being able to
renegotiate uh the Northern Ireland
protocol as he did
um it is it is worth pointing out you
know this this peace agreement obviously
we've all been looking at it over this
as you know historic 25-year anniversary
it is a template you know if you're
involved in you know he studies or
international relations this is held up
as a model of a successful negotiation
and so of course it's incredibly
disturbing
um to hear These Warnings of its
fragility but it's worth saying that we
have been hearing These Warnings for the
last few years particularly in regard to
brexit and the effect that that has had
we saw Peter Hayne who's a former
Northern Ireland secretary was writing
in the guardian I think a few days ago
and pointing out the disruptive effect
of brexit in that the idea of a hard
border between
Northern Ireland and the Republic of
Ireland has just reignited questions
that people didn't have and haven't had
for decades over citizenship over
identity over self-determination and so
that has had a disruptive Factor on you
know what is what was an incredible and
historic agreement which we are marking
the anniversary of tomorrow
let's move to the mirror and just
fitting some news on the coronation more
details revealed this evening Sebastian
yes and we've got details of the route
which is going to be a lot shorter uh
than the one that was taken by Queen
Elizabeth II that the last coronation
and on actually on the front page of
another paper the telegraph they're
saying that it may well be ticketed to
get tickets along the route that the
king will be taking on his way to the
coronation at Westminster Abbey but yes
obviously May the 6th less than a month
away when that is going to happen a very
historic day for the country and I think
the king is taking a very good approach
to this he's not trying to reenact what
happened in the 1950s nor is he getting
away with the Pomp and pageanty that
many people enjoy and associate with the
royal family so it strikes me as if
they're getting a good balance here
they're trying to keep the best out of
the traditions and the historic ceremony
but they're also trying to sort of you
know bring it up to date and not make it
to grandiose and to over the top so yeah
they will be hearing a bit more about it
and I've also seen on Twitter tonight
there is an official a coronation Emoji
so if you tweet hashtag coronation you
get a little crown that goes there so
even though the rest of Twitter is
slightly falling apart under Elon Musk
it's hopefully that bit of it is still
working on May the 6th look forward to
that emoji and